bonjour et bienvenue pour ce premier
casse-tête du mois d'août puisque oui
nous sommes en plein mois d'août
aujourd'hui c'est pas un casse tête que
j'ai acheté j'ai reçu cette boîte avec
cette lettre que je vais vous lire
bonjour fabien je m'appelle fabrice je
suis grand fan de la chaîne youtube ce
très gentil fabrice j'avais adoré la
vidéo avec le casse tête que mr bolt
avait fabriqué pour toi la holy boxe que
vous pouvez retrouver au dessus de moi
ce casse tête ne devrait pas trop être
trop compliqué pour toi message qu'en
général je donne une heure pour l'ouvrir
et que personne n'y arrivais sans avoir
besoin d aide
est ce que serait une manipulation pour
le défier ça marche je tirais te dire
que quand tu va le résoudre certaines
pièces mobiles ont un peu de mal à
coulisser entre elle et qu'il ne faut
pas avoir peur de forcer légèrement par
moments dans la limite du raisonnable je
possède la chaîne youtube mais car
science cette boîte m'a demandé des
dizaines voire en centaines d'heures de
travail [ __ ] c'est ouf depuis début
décembre et je suis très fier du
résultat fille en ce moment je fais
également une version non montée de la
résolution du casse-tête que vous pouvez
trouver sur ma chaîne secondaire s'est
sorti en même temps que cette vidéo lien
dans la description
donc c'est la même vidéo mais sans aucun
montage
loïc plan badass du casse tête on est
donc sur une fabrication maison de la
part de fabrice de ce gros cube ce gros
cube à une indication déjà c'est qu'il a
des ces sortes de patin donc ça veut
dire que ça se tient dans ce sens alors
là déjà
ici je peux appuyer comme vous pouvez le
constater la sur ce côté là rien de
spécial si ce n'est un trou et un bout
de ferraille ici
de ce côté là deux trous pour l'instant
je peux enfin appuyé mais je vais
réessayer d'appuyer après quand je me
mettrai à plat parce que là c'est pas
dit que ça empêche pas là il ya un gros
bloc et je sens un tout petit peu
amovible
ça ça bouge et là je reviens à mon point
de départ c'est ça ok donc la gc
d'appuyer un petit peu pas là il ya un
truc un marché je poussais dessus ici
nasa appuie aussi à première chose il se
passe qui si il sort un petit quelque
chose
en appuyant la donc ce cube là qui sort
et ce truc là qui sort et qui est qui et
qui est amovible avec des inscriptions
dessus y'a rien de ce qui se passe ok
donc on vient de libérer cette pièce là
une espèce de petite pige avec ici des
inscriptions j'imagine qu'elles sont
quand même pas là au hasard ça je vais
essayer de le mettre partout dans l où
il ya des troupes il ya deux trous 1
l'as monaco là ok ça débloque quelque
chose loïc ça a débloqué au bout du truc
qui n'en finit plus et qui est plus
grand que la boîte en lui-même c'est
vraiment la même taille ou une deuxième
tiges qui comporte également des
inscriptions avec un espèce de
séquencier qui descend de plus en plus
si je tente dans ce sens là ça ça doit
être un aimant qui leur tenait à
l'intérieur c'est ça ok donc j'essaie de
tiges appelé excusez moi j'avais pas
fait le point en fait ça ça fait tomber
l'espèce de barrett que vous voyez ici
et ça les fait tomber des deux côtés
donc je pense qu'on est sur la suite du
casse tête et qui ont des symboles
également comme vous pouvez le constater
ici là il ya trois symboles là il ya un
trou est un symbole trou un symbole
il ya surtout un trou ici dans chacun
d'entre eux
alors est ce que ça donne servir à
quelque chose ou pas maintenant ça passe
par ici
ainsi d'accord un petit peu de jeu
est-ce que ça me sert à les bloquer est
ce que c'est un intérêt ah bah non je
suis bête je suis vraiment con ça devait
les bloquer ici de l'intérieur par
rapport à la distance qui les a donc je
sais pas pourquoi mais là ça me retient
quand je mets ça là dedans ça le retient
la produits tous là au contraire ça
m'empêche d'appuyer dessus
donc il doit avoir un trou à l'intérieur
de ces pièces en bois est donc en le
mettant la balle ça doit rentrer dans un
trou qu'il empêche de tomber et en le
mettant là comme ça d'ailleurs se donne
une pièce assez longue en fait un
rectangulaire ça le retient complètement
ok alors là tu alors je les lui je les
range est d'accord il ya plusieurs trous
dansez dansez bordel ans parce que tout
à l'heure je l' ai mis dedans quand eux
étaient rentrés est ce que chaque trait
serait pas une position d'un trou si
hockey ça veut dire qu'il ya plein de
trous et plein de positions ça veut dire
qu'il ya un espèce de code à faire sur
un deux trois symboles 4-5-6 symbole je
pense qu'il ya une combinaison à trouver
maintenant comment je sais pas encore
mais sûrement avec les symboles qui est
aussi un de toute manière il y en a ici
il y en a ici un allah je pense quelle
combinaison à trouver je ne sais pas
encore comment
est-ce que ça russe ça si on les combine
ça donne pas un des symboles qui alla
donc là si je fusionne ces deux symboles
dans ma tête ça ferait en fait un grand
salon garderai ça avec une plus grande
diagonale au mieux je vais essayer de
voir non plus là non plus là non plus ce
qu'il y en a en dessous non non pas
parce que je me méfie exact je laisse ça
là ça c'est exactement la fusion de ces
deux symboles je pense pas que ce soit
hasard mon petit mais car science loïc
nantais la witch affecté là je te
propose pour gagner du temps je vais
essayer de trouver tous les symboles de
faire une légère
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs j'ai pas mal
réfléchi
vous verrez ça dans la version non qu'on
paie si vous voulez voir la réflexion
longue
en fait j'ai commencé à recopier les
symboles au début j'essayais de les
fusionner ça ne fonctionnait pas ensuite
je me suis je vais les recopier pour pas
avoir à tourner tout le temps j'ai
commencé par recopier ça me dit tiens
c'est marrant il y en a pas un qui a le
même nombre de traits je m'en suis
aperçu en écrivant ensuite j'ai recopié
tout ce qu'il y avait ici le minutier 1
c'est marrant les deux symboles qui
assure chaque plaque ont toujours le
même nombre de traits c'est à dire qu'au
départ on a bien deux traits de traits
ensuite j'ai trois traits trois traits 4
et 4 très cintrée 5 créée mais ok ça
peut pas être un hasard
du coup je me suis échauffé g j'ai
reproduit en fait les quatre barrettes
avec les deux côtés et j'ai noté le
nombre de trades chaque symbole à chaque
fois sur une barre est il n'y a pas de
case qui ont un nombre de traits
identique sur chaque symbole genre celle
ci la première il ya deux traits trois
traits cinq traits et de l'autre côté 4
et 6 très donc très clairement il y à
une séquence sachant ça ça nous donne un
ordre une indication d'ordre je pense
que le nombre de traits correspond au
nombre de traits qu'on doit retrouver
sur les barrettes en passant de la
première jusqu'à là jusqu'à la dernière
et en cherchant sur le trône je sais pas
si je suis très clair oui les amateurs
de post it vous régaler ça fait plaisir
pour moi ce serait un deux trois cas
donc je vais essayer comme ça puis ça
marche pas je vais essayer de toutes les
autres actions
donc le premier il ya quatre retraits
dont quatre très j'en ai aucun cas de
trail ainsi via lui je vais le placer
comme ça le deuxième il me faut trois
traits trois traits ces deux côtés donc
je vais le passer comme ça le troisième
il faut cinq traits donc il est de ce
côté là une deux trois quatre cinq voilà
je veux c'est comme ça et le quatrième
une faute deux traits donc ici et demi
je vais leur mettre dans sa position de
départ
attention de pas mais dans sa lettre il
a dit qu'il ne pouvait y avoir du jeu
ou alors passer de l'autre côté parce
que là on avait vu qu'ici lui rentrer
complètement aussi molle vais essayer
d'ici ça rentre
c'est bon signe 4 ensuite le deuxième
c'était trois traits 1-2-3 très ça
rentre oui ça rend ok le quatrième c'est
cinq traits lui il fait ça me ferait ça
rentre et le dernier fait deux très
jeunes la ligne avec de très noir et ça
ok donc là j'ai appuyé et ça m'a fait
sortir ce cette petite pièce là ce petit
big two new qui était retenu par un
aimant à voir maintenant ou est ce
qu'elle peut s'insérer à ça me bloque
ensemble à et ça m'a débloqué ça aussi
je peux pas le sortir plus un peut-être
qu'il faut que je leur mette dedans
attends toi on verra je vois tu sais
après on peut pas va sortir à si haut
[ __ ] si ça marche il faut appuyer sur
lui et ça ne débloque jusqu'au bout uni
jusqu'au bout ok donc là on a un petit
cube où il ya une petite flèche de
rotation je ne put un jeu les sentiments
là avec les aimons si je suis le sens de
cette petite plage de rotation je vais
devoir le tourner comme ça et je le suis
de faire ça en fait c'était comme ça
donc je claque comme ça peut-être
appuyant sur le bouton
ah c'est pas ça bon je peux pas rentrer
je suis sûr qu'il faut leur rentrer
comme ça claque
le mec je leur emboîtent non si je les
alignent peut-être que je lâche plus
romaine
ah oui on est pas jusqu'au bout là il ya
deux points noirs et une flèche et à la
flèche qui est ici que vous êtes fait
voir il ya un point noir la est un point
noir là et j'ai cette petite pièce ici
avec léman mais ça c'est clairement des
aimants qui pour le coup la route n'est
équivaut en passant de vente dont les
excès
[Musique]
ah [ __ ] ça un nom en lui il bloque des
fois quand il a envie aux aveugles il
fallait qu'il soit rentré je sais pas
pourquoi mais tous en fête à [ __ ] il
fallait qu'ils soient tous rentrés
fallait qu'ils soient tous rentrés et
lui il est rentré je crois que c'est
quand j'ai appuyé sur lui aussi en même
temps hélas en poussant j'ai senti qu'il
allait se passer quelque chose dont je
pense que c'est la fin je vous paie
comme ça je fais un beau plan dessus
petite musique de faim pousse et arrête
la visite de fin abbas il faut peut-être
que je continue de pousser sur lui alors
tac je pousse en fait sur le deuxième en
moins de temps lui là où il tient tout
seul
oui la fin de la faim au c'est juste un
croc tiroirs énorme avec un petit mot
m'écoeure science viendra description de
make her science n'hésitez pas à aller
voir sa chaîne et du coup la vidéo de la
construction de la boîte j'irai la voir
après
bien joué merci de m'avoir accordé un
peu de temps libre pour résoudre un
casse tête j'espère que tu as a pris
beaucoup de plaisir
en cherchant comment ouvrir cette boîte
à bientôt écoute franchement bravo parce
que hal était vraiment complexe
j'ai beaucoup apprécié le fait qu' une
séquence comme ça tac tac tac à trouver
mais qu'ils soient pas non plus
délirante est introuvable
j'aime bien quand les casse-têtes ils
ont un chemin logique excellente
réalisation tu vois si si je pouvais
dire un truc c'est que ya pas trop de
déco mais au moins mon
on regarde se perdre et pas ailleurs
mais dans la real je j'ai hâte de voir
comment tu l'a construite parce que je
comprends pas comment on peut être doué
à faire des choses comme ça moi ça me
dépasse je vais essayer de la mettre à
reset mais merci à toi ben bravo
mesdames et messieurs j'espère que vous
avez autant apprécié que moi ce cas
peut-être fait maison mais qui vaut
largement des casse tête que j'ai pu
acheter et qui était un peu décevant
donc un grand bravo vous avez sa chaîne
de la description vous avez la version
non honte et de cette résolution sur ma
chaîne secondaire qui est dans la
description également ce casse tête va
tourner il est à gagner sur instagram
avec la photo qui se trouve ici
n'hésitez pas à y aller quand vous
l'aurez résolu de l'offrir à quelqu'un
d'autre et cetera faisons le vivre merci
beaucoup à très bientôt